When President Biden took office,
the deficit over the next ten years
was expected to be about $12.2
trillion, thanks to a boatload
of new spending approved during
Biden's first year, that's climbed
to 14.5 trillion.
One way or another, that shortfall
has to be accounted for by cutting
spending, raising taxes or printing
money. So what does the new
Inflation Reduction Act do to
address the problem?
It doesn't cut unnecessary spending
or wasteful government programs.
It raises taxes.
And those tax increases will only
reduce the deficit by about $300
billion or 2%
of planned borrowing over the next
ten years. In other words, even
assuming no new spending,
we'd still need about 50 more
bills just like this one,
to not add any more debt in the
next decade. And the bill doesn't do
anything to reduce the $30
trillion in debt we've already
accumulated.
Even that small amount of deficit
reduction requires a massive
corporate tax increase that will
hurt the economy.
There's also a plan to squeeze more
money out of taxpayers by hiring
87,000 new IRS
agents and beefing up the agency's
audit powers.
It's true that this bill is the
first major piece of legislation to
move through Congress that would
have even a slightly positive
impact on future federal deficits
since at least the middle of the
Obama years.
But it's not a serious attempt
to grapple with our coming fiscal
nightmare. The actual driver of
future deficits are entitlement
programs. Social Security and
Medicare in particular, are expected
to bring up massive budget deficits
over the next decade.
Because they're structured like a
Ponzi scheme in which today's
workers are paying the benefits of
today's beneficiaries as
baby boomers age, and there aren't
enough working age Americans to
cover what they're owed.
The system is starting to collapse.
Yes, $300 billion
might sound like a lot of money,
but in the context of government
spending under Bush, Obama, Trump
and Biden and the exploding
cost of elder care entitlements,
it's actually not very much
money at all.